in diesem sich nun zu Ende neenden Jahr
2023 jetzt sich die illegale und in
vielen Aspekten verbrecherische Invasion
der US geführten Streitkräfte gegen das
brutale Regime von Saddam Hussein im
Irak zum 20 mal wahrscheinlich sprechen
wir über einen Krieg der die Jugendzeit
all der Menschen zwischen 30 und 40
geprägt hat die diesen Kanal sehen ich
bin sicher viele von euch haben noch
Bilder im Kopf die bereits Teil der
Geschichte sind so berühmte bilder wie
dieses hier ich bin mir auch sicher dass
sich viele von euch an die großen
demonstra und Proteste gegen den Krieg
erinnern und das ist eine sehr
interessante Sache denn dieser Krieg
fand etwa zur gleichen Zeit statt wieder
afghanistanrieg allerdings bekam die
militärische Intervention in Afghanistan
eine viel bessere Presse jeder schien
damals Verständnis zu haben dass
Afghanistan eine angemessene Reaktion
auf die Anschläge vom 11 September
darstellt im Gegensatz dazu war der
Irakkrieg jedoch hochgradig umstritten
zwei bis dre Jahre lang war die gesamte
Popkultur vom Krieg durchdrungen
Künstler wie Madonna und große Hollywood
Stars wie Tim Robbins und Kim Basinger
sprachen sich gegen die US-Invasion im
Irak aus kein Blut für Öl war der Slogan
der Massenproteste gegen den Krieg die
auf der ganzen Welt stattfanden nun
seltsamerweise zweifelt 20 Jahre später
niemand daran dass der Krieg in
Afghanistan ein totaler fehschlag war
der damit endete dass die Taliban nach
einer eher peinlichen Evakuierung der
westlichen Streitkräfte wieder an der
Macht sind inzwischen befinden sich noch
etwa 2500 US-Soldaten im Irak und alles
deutet darauf hin dass sie es nicht
eilig haben ihn zu verlassen der
irakische Premierminister unterstützt
eine unbefristete US Truppenpräsenz
konkret bedeutet dies dass ein US-Soldat
nach Afghanistan nicht einreisen kann
selbst wenn er oder sie es wollte
während sie im Irak fast willkommen sind
nun nicht ganz aber ihr versteht worauf
ich hinaus will die Frage ist also warum
hat der Irakkrieg überhaupt
stattgefunden inwi weit war ein
Fehlschlag und wie sieht es im Irak
aktuell aus heute werden wir diese
Fragen beantworten aber nicht nur das
wir werden euch in einem folgevideo das
schon bald erscheinen wird auch erklären
warum dieser Krieg ein gigantischer
strategischer Fehler der USA war und wie
sehr er den Iran gestärkt hat und
natürlich werden wir dann auch die üblen
Machenschaften der Bush chany romsfeld
Mafia beleuchten die für ihn
verantwortlich ist also vergesst bitte
nicht unseren Kanal zu abonnieren um
auch die zweite Folge unserer kleinen
irakserie nicht zu verpassen gerade in
der heutigen Zeit in der der Kampf gegen
das Böse wieder auf der Tagesordnung
steht sind die Lektionen daraus
wichtiger den
als erstes müssen wir euch heute aber
über das aktuelle black riday Angebot
unseres truen Sponsors surfchark
erzählen der das heutige Video überhaupt
erst möglich gemacht hat denn solltet
ihr noch kein VPN haben ist dies nur die
einmalige Gelegenheit es so günstig wie
noch nie zu bekommen wusstet ihr z.B
dass viele Firmen wie Social Airlines
ganz unterschiedliche Preise anbieten
können je nachdem von welchem Land aus
man bestellt bzw ein Ticket Bucht aber
zum Glück kann man solche
diskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe eines
VPNs überlisten und dann richtig Geld
sparen surfshar VPN ist aber ein
wirklich empfehlenswertes und sicheres
VPN welches z.B keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mitlockt ein Virtual
Private networkus VPN ist aber nicht nur
zum Geld sparen geeignet es kann ein
auch vor so mancher größeren
gefahrschützen die im Netz lauert
natürlich muss man nach wie vor Umsicht
walten lassen und wissen was man tut
aber es stellt hierfür ein werkzeugleich
mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwert es in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktion Netz
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen
z.B mit den integrierten cleanw das alle
unerwünschten Cookies und Pop-ups blockt
weiterer Vorteil ein open ist dass ihr
so tun könnt als wäret ihr an einem
anderen Ort so könnt ihr z.B auf
Websites und internetdi zugreifen die
dem Land ihr gerade seid nicht verfügbar
wären ob der halben oder im Urlaub damit
schlagt dir Zensur und geoblocking ein
Schnippchen Netflix und andere streame
Diere Inhalte nur in den USA Anbieten
von Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfshar kein Problem aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles denn mit nur einem
surfchar Kol könnt ihr wirklich alle
eure Endgeräte im VPN registrieren
Handys Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart
TV so und wenn ihr den Rabattcode
politikde angeht bekommt ihr von surar
im Rahmen des Black Friday special auch
noch zusätzliche se Monate gratis dazu
den Link zu diesem Angebot findet ihr in
der Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
nichts los besorgt euch sur und greift
damit gleichzeitig auch uns finanziell
unter die Arme das könnt ihr übrigens
auch direkt mit Hilfe der spendenlinks
die ich euch ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind euch
für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit HT ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch
mehr und noch bessere Videos zu liefern
so und jetzt lasst uns in den Mittleren
Osten aufbrechen um die ganze Misere des
Irak aufzurollen
[Musik]
aufgepasst
der
[Musik]
Filmbösewicht es gab eine Zeit damals in
den 1990er Jahren als die Sowjetunion
schon weniger beängstigend war als Akte
X und die chinesische Bedrohung eher wie
eine werbechallenge in einem asiatischen
all you can eat Restaurant erschien
damals war Saddam Hussein viele Jahre
lang die Ikone des Bösen in der
Zeichentrick Serie South Park wurde er
böser als der Teufel selbst dargestellt
er war so böse dass das Weiße Haus im
Krieg zwischen dem Irak und dem Iran in
den 80er Jahren schließlich das Regime
der ayatollas unterstützte
wahrscheinlich um sicherzustellen dass
niemand am Ende gewinnt und beide Seiten
verlieren Mitte der 1980er Jahre brach
der Iran kontraskandal aus die Regierung
von US-Präsident Ronald Reagan verkaufte
heimlich Waffen an den Iran ein Land das
unter einem uswaffenembargo Stand aber
selbst das war nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs mit dem erhaltenen Geld
finanzierte das Weiße Haus nämlich die
Kontras eine bewaffnete Gruppe die für
den Sturz der nikaraguanischen Regierung
kämpfte diese war aus der
sandinistischen Revolution
hervorgegangen und in Washington
ziemlich unbeliebt beide Aktionen der
Verkauf von Waffen an den Iran und die
Finanzierung der Kontras wurden vom
US-Senat
verboten daher kam es erst 1988 zum
Frieden zwischen dem Irak und dem Iran
und es überrascht nicht dass keine der
beiden Seiten am Ende gewonnen hat die
Grenzen blieben an der gleichen Stelle
an der sie vor dem Krieg waren aber fast
eine Million Menschen verloren dabei ihr
Leben und nach 8 Jahren der Verwüstung
war auch die Wirtschaft beider Länder am
Boden zerstört und als dieser Krieg zu
Ende war begann kuvit eine mit Saddam
Hussein Verbündete petromonarchie das
Geld vom Irak zurückzufordern dass es
ihm für den Kampf gegen die aatollas
geliehen hatte wir sprechen hier nicht
von weniger als 14 Milliarden Dollar die
Beziehungen zwischen den beiden Ländern
begannen sich anschließend zu
verschlechtern der Irak kuvit
Beschuldigte sein Öl zu stehlen es
handelte sich um eine haltlose
Anschuldigung aber Saddams Regime
bereitete damit den Einmarsch in kuvit
vor welch Ironie des Schicksals dass es
nur 13 Jahre später selbst Opfer eines
fabrizierten kriegsvorwands werden
sollte aber soweit sind wir noch nicht
im August 1919 marschierte Saddam
Hussein also in Kuweit ein die
internationale Gemeinschaft verurteilte
diese Invasion aufs
Schärfste
ganze 5 Monate lang versuchte die
Diplomatie Saddam Hussein zum Rückzug
seiner Truppen aus kuwet zu bewegen der
UN Sicherheitsrat verabschiedete fünf
Resolutionen zu diesem Zweck schließlich
startete am 16 januar 1991 eine
internationale Koalition aus 34 Ländern
unter der Führung der USA und im Auftrag
der unu eine Militäraktion ihr Ziel war
es Saddams Invasionsarmee aus Kuweit zum
Rückzug zu zwingen die UN-Resolution 660
die diese Operation unterstützte wurde
einstimmig angenommen
und so begann der Golfkrieg der erste in
der Geschichte der live im Fernsehen
übertragen wurde die sogenannte
Operation Wüstensturm dauerte 6 Wochen
und war ein voller Erfolg eigentlich
hätten die USA Saddam Hussein damals
bereits leicht stürzen können general
Norman Schwarzkopf der für die
Militäroperation verantwortlich war
sagte er habe Präsident Bush senior um
eine Woche mehr gebeten um Saddam zu
erledigen doch das Weiße Haus lehnte
einfach ab in einem Interview für die
pbssendung Frontline gab Schwarzkopf
ausgut darüber warum Saddam 1991 nicht
gestürzt wurde schaut es euch an ich
wäre nach Bagdad gegangen und hätte mir
Saddam Hussein geschnappt aber das war
keine emotionale Entscheidung sondern
eine strategische und strategisch waren
wir klug genug den Krieg und den Frieden
zu gewinnen wenn Sadam morgen ersetzt
würde würde er wahrscheinlich durch
jemanden ersetzt werden der genauso
schlimm oder noch schlimmer ist als er
general Norman Schwarzkopf und die
jüngeren unter euch werden vielleicht
denken okay mir ist schon klar dass
Saddam Hussein Ende des letzten
Jahrhunderts der Bösewicht schlecht hin
war aber was hat er eigentlich getan um
diesen Titel zu verdienen und viele von
euch werden sich andererseits Fragen
moment mal wenn er so böse war warum
wurde er dann nicht 1991 schon gestürzt
nun Saddams Geschichte begann in den
60er Jahren in einer Ehra voller
Staatsstreiche im Irak damals schaffte
er es seine Position so stark zu
verbessern dass er dank seiner Führung
der arabischen sozialistischen badpartei
aus dem Exil kommend zum Vizepräsidenten
der Republik
Aufstieg
[Musik]
beim arabischen Sozialismus handeltte es
sich bitte des 20 Jahrhunderts um eine
sehr beliebte ideologische Strömung es
geht dabei um eine Mischung aus drei
entscheidenden Elementen Sozialismus mit
einer zentralisierten Staatswirtschaft
sekularismus da sie dagegen sind die
religiöse Führung über die politische
Führung zu stellen und Militarismus mit
einer herausragenden Rolle der
Streitkräfte bei der Organisation des
Staates der arabische Sozialismus begann
als Panarabismus mit dem Ziel alle
Araber in einem einzigen Heimatland zu
vereinen da sie die bestehenden Grenzen
für künstlich hielten doch schließlich
führten die Auseinandersetzungen
zwischen den bathtistischen Führern der
verschiedenen Länder zum Entstehen
nationalistischer Zweige der Bart auf
diese Weise konnte Saddam Hussein jede
Einmischung zurückweisen und wurde 1979
offiziell zum Präsidenten des Irak
ernannt er regierte mit eiserner Faust
und umgab sich mit einer Elite die aus
Sunniten Bestand einer religiösen
Minderheit zu der auch er gehörte und
die kaum ein Fünftel der irakischen
völkerung ausmachte anschließend
investierte Saddam das Geld aus der
Ölindustrie in die Armee sie wurde
dadurch zur viertgrößten Armee der Welt
was für ein Land das damals nur 18
Millionen Einwohner hatte nicht gerade
eine schlechte Leistung ist und an
diesem Punkt werden viele von euch
vielleicht denken na ja Saddam klingt
einfach nach einem normalen Diktator wie
aus dem Lehrbuch und ja das stimmt aber
es ist nicht nur so dass Saddam sein
eigenes Volk einfach nur unterdrückt hat
er hat es sogar mit Chemiewaffen
[Musik]
gemordet ganz genau ihr habt euch nicht
verhört in den 1980er Jahren verübte
Saddam Hussein eine Reihe von Massakern
an der kurdischen Bevölkerung im
Nordirak die sogenannte Operation Anfall
die zur Zerstörung von 4500 Dörfern und
zur Ermordung von R 180.000 Zivilisten
führte wurde von mehreren Ländern als
Völkermord bezeichnet grausamste
Episoden wie das Massaker von halajaba
einer Stadt die mit Chemiewaffen
bombardiert wurde und nur in einer Nacht
5000 Tote forderte sind Teil der
dunkelsten Geschichte der Menschheit und
der Hauptverantwortliche hierfür ist
Saddam Hussein aber sein wir nicht naiv
das war wahrscheinlich nicht der Grund
dafür warum der Westen so heftig auf die
Invasion in Kuweit reagiert hat denn ein
weiterer guter Grund liegt im dinosaft
der Irak war damals ein reiches Land in
der arabischen Welt das große Mengen an
Öl und Gas produziert hat und zusammen
mit Kuwait wäre seine Macht zu groß
gewesen vergess nicht dass wir über eine
Zeit sprechen in der es noch kein
Fracking gab das Öl des Nahen Ostens war
für die USA essentiell wichtig
gleichzeitig und aus dem gleichen Grund
war der Irak aber auch extrem wichtig um
weiter Rohöl zu fördern um die Preise
auf den internationalen Märkten stabil
zu halten und wisst ihr was das könnte
eine Erklärung dafür sein warum die USA
das Regime von Saddam nicht beenden
wollten ja er war ein abscheulicher
Diktator aber er hatte das Land unter
Kontrolle und musste Öl verkaufen um um
das Militär zu finanzieren und so begann
ein Spiel von Zuckerbrot und Peitsche
falls du noch mal aus deinen Stiefeln
wachsen solltest lieber Sadam versetzen
wir dir einen Schlag und drohen mit
einer Invasion aber wenn du dich
benimmst lassen wir dich in Ruhe denn so
bleibt der Irak wenigstens stabil tja
und das alles änderte sich dann im Jahr
2003 und warum nun ihr ahnt es sich ja
schon kein Blut für
Öl
die Anschläge vom 11 September 2001
erschütterten die amerikanische
Supermacht die USA waren im eigenen Land
von al-Qaida angegriffen worden und
Präsident Bush Junior hatte einen Krieg
gegen den Terror gestartet dies führte
zum Einmarsch in Afghanistan wo das
Talibanregime Osama bin Laden
beherberkte dem Anführer der al-Qaida
gelang es den US-Truppen zu entkommen
also begann das Weiße Haus überall nach
Feinden zu suchen die ihm helfen könnten
und es überrascht nicht dass Saddam
Hussein Erfolgsbilanz ihn auf diese
schwarze Liste brachte natürlich hat die
Zeit dann gezeigt dass es sich bei den
angeblichen Verbindungen zwischen
al-Qaida und salam husin um
fadenscheinige Anschuldigung handelte
aber hier reichte es der bushchregierung
als Vorwand dass beide einfach die USA
hasasten es gelang ihr den UN
Sicherheitsrat zur Verabschiedung der
Resolution
1441 zu bewegen in der die
internationale Gemeinschaft in Irak zur
Zusammenarbeit mit den
abrüstungsinspektoren aufforderte aber
Washington wollte mehr man drängte
darauf S husin ein Ultimatum zu stellen
allerdings meine Lieben visualpitik
Zuschauer lief dieses Ultimatum ab und
im März 2003 beschloss das Weiße Haus
auf eigene Faust in den Krieg zu ziehen
bis zum letzten Moment versuchte Bush
die Welt von der Gefahr der Untätigkeit
zu
[Musik]
überzeugen infolgessen war der
offizielle Grund für den Einmarsch in
den Irak dass Saddam Hussein die
berüchtigten Massenvernichtungswaffen
gehabt
[Musik]
hätte das alles stellte sich hinterher
als dreiste Lüge heraus und schon damals
gab es Zweifel s dass ein großer Teil
der internationalen Gemeinschaft gegen
die Intervention war trotzdem genehmigte
der US-Kongress im Oktober 2002 den
Angriff auf den Irak falls die
Diplomatie scheintern sollte und
Präsident George W bush hatte die breite
Unterstützung von Senatoren beider
Parteien wie z.B den Demokraten Joseph
Biden den derzeitigen Präsidenten der
USA im Gegensatz zum Golfkrieg gab es
dieses Mal allerdings keine große
internationale Koalition die mitmachte
nur Großbritannien schickte ein starkes
Truppenkontingent während die
europäischen Regierungen gespalten waren
zwischen denen die gegen den Krieg waren
wie Frankreich und Deutschland und denen
die die Intervention unterstützten wie
Spanien Italien und große Teile
Mittelosteuropas vielleicht hat die
Invasion gerade wegen dieser Spaltung
große Kontroversen ausgelöst und zu
massiven Protesten in der ganzen Welt
geführt niemand verstand warum der Irak
überfallen werden musste und Künstler
und Intellektuelle führten
internationale Volksbewegungen dagegen
an doch trotz allem war die Invasion ein
großer militärischer Erfolg die US-Armee
eroberte Bagdad in nur 3 Wochen und nur
sech Wochen nach Kriegsbeginn verkündete
Präsident Bush das Ende der großen
Militäroperationen im
Irak er tat dies unter einem großen
Schild mit der Aufschrift mission
accomplished Mission erfüllt was im
Laufe der Zeit stark kritisiert wurde da
das Land noch lange nicht befriedet war
außerdem setzte sich bushch in dieser
Rede ein neues Ziel nämlich einen
demokratischen Irak zu
erreichen
Bagdad war erobert und die große Statue
von Saddam Hussein war gestürzt worden
die irakische Armee war zerschlagen
worden allerdings gab es noch viele
offene Fragen die wichtigste davon war
dass der Diktator noch nicht gefangen
genommen worden war sein Palast war zwar
eingenommen worden aber es gab keine
Spur von ihm seinem Geld oder seinen
angeblichen
Massenvernichtungswaffen es dauerte ein
halbes Jahr bis Hadam endlich gefunden
wurde nachdem er sich in einem Loch im
Boden versteckt hatte er wurde den neuen
irakischen Behörden übergeben und der
Prozess gegen ihn endete auf die im Irak
einzig mögliche Weise er wurde zum Tode
durch den Strang verurteilt und an
dieser Stelle ist es wichtig zu erwähnen
dass Sadam Hussein bis zum Schluss
trotzig war so reagierte er auf sein
Urteil
theoretisch war der irakrieg als ein
großer Erfolg für die USA sie hatten
ihre Dominanz als militärische
Supermacht bekräftigt und hatten allen
Grund zufrieden zu sein aber natürlich
war dies nur der erste Schritt auf dem
Weg zur Demokratisierung des Irak denn
jetzt kam das große Dilemma kann man
wirklich einen Staat von außen aufbauen
genau das neen wir jetzt mal genauer
unter die Lupe
aufgepasst ist es möglich Demokratie
durchzusetzen viele glauben ja bushch
habe sich getäuscht weil er dachte er
könne einem Land mit militärischen
Mitteln die Demokratie aufzwingen da
Saddam Hussein den Irak einer
verbrecherischen Diktatur unterworfen
hatte ging das Weiße Haus davon aus dass
alle im Irak nur so darauf warteten dass
die US-Truppen eintrafen um sie von dem
tyran zu befreien und dann würde alle
glücklich und zufrieden Zusammenleben
das Problem dabei ist dass man am
nächsten Tag ja mit dem Aufbau eines
Staates beginnen muss der unter anderem
komplett zerstört ist die Idee in ein
zerstörtes Land zu kommen und dort eine
Demokratie zu errichten hat schon in
Deutschland und Japan funktioniert wie
wir alle wissen das haben wir maßgeblich
den USA zu verdanken nach dem Koreakrieg
machte man in Südkorea dasselbe
zugegeben dort herrschte in den ersten
Jahrzehnten ein autoritäres System und
eine Militärdiktatur aber mit der
Unterstützung der USA wurde es
schließlich zu einer funktionierenden
Demokratie wenn wir allerdings auf den
Irak und Afghanistan blicken scheint
alles etwas komplizierter zu
sein im Jahr 2021 beendeten die USA den
Afghanistankrieg und ihr habt alle
gesehen was für ein Disaster das war wir
haben darüber mehrere Videos auf
visualpolitik gedreht und ich werde sie
euch verlinken die zarte afghanische
Demokratie wurde von den Taliban
zerstört und im Irak sind die Dinge auch
nicht viel besser gelaufen Obama
kündigte 2011 den vollständigen Abzug
der US-Truppen an aber die junge
irakische Demokratie sah sich nicht in
der Lage sich gegen ihre Feinde zu
behaupten so dass sie nur drei Jahre
später die Rückkehr von ankel Sam
forderten die USA entsenden neue Truppen
in den Irak um gegen den islamischen
Staat zu kämpfen die USA haben im Irak
viele Fehler gemacht sie setzten auf
Führer die sektiererische und ethnische
Spaltungen förderten um Unterstützung
für sich selbst zu gewinnen es handelte
sich um Politiker die eher für ihre
eigenen als für die nationalen
Interessen iierten und so war es sehr
schwierig einen neuen Staat für alle
Iraker aufzubauen ein weiterer Fehler
war die Armee aufzulösen diese
Entscheidung ermutigte Saddams ehemalige
Truppen dazu einen Aufstand gegen die
Eindringlinge zu unterstützen ein
permanenter Aufstand der ebenso schwer
zu bekämpfen wie zu besiegen war die
Realität ist allerdings dass es im Irak
erhebliche Veränderung gegeben hat seit
2005 werden freie Wahlen abgehalten und
trotz der Schwäche der jungen irakischen
Institutionen kann man sagen dass es 20
Jahre nach Saddam Hussein eine Funktion
Demokratie im Irak gibt in der die
Machtwechsel relativ friedlich
stattfinden und wo die Sicherheit auf
den Straßen immerhin zunimmt auch die
Ölproduktion gibt uns einen guten
Hinweis darauf wie sich der Irak
entwickelt der derzeit mit mehr als 4
Millionen Barrel pro Tag der zweitgrößte
Produzent der OPEC ist was wir aber auf
gar keinen Fall sagen können ist dass im
Irak alles superlufe und Bagdad zu Las
Vegas geworden ist ein Problem der
irakischen Demokratie das auch in
Afghanistan auftrat ist die
astronomische
Korruption
von Plünderung auf den Straßen bis zur
Plünderung der Staatskasse in einer
Weise die Saddams vergoldete AK47
bescheiden aussehen lässt aber über die
aktuellen Probleme des Irak werden wir
wie gesagt im nächsten Video dieser
Reihe sprechen immerhin können wir
festhalten dass George W Bush es
geschafft hat aus dem Irak eine
Demokratie zu machen aber zu einem viel
zu hohen Preis den Preis unzähliger
Menschenleben außerdem musste er dafür
eine Menge Geld des us-steuerzahlers
verballern aber das war wahrscheinlich
Bestandteil seines Plans denn die USA
haben wirklich extrem viel Geld für
diesen Krieg ausgegeben 800 Milliarden
Dollar nach konservativen Schätzungen
und Billionen von Dollar nach anderen
etwas großzügigeren Schätzungen allein
schon diese riesige Spannweite und
intransparent zeigt schon dass für
manche Beteiligten eine gewaltiger
Reibach zu machen war aber aus
geopolitischer Sicht wird Bagdad nun am
Ende von niemanden regiert der wahrlich
nicht als Marionette Washingtons
bezeichnet werden
kann
in einer Demokratie regiert nämlich die
Mehrheit und im Irak ist die Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung schiitisch deswegen
regieren heute die schiitischen
Fraktionen im Irak die vom Iran am
meisten Unterstützung erhalten haben der
größte Fehler bei der Invasion war dass
es also keinen realistischen Plan für
die Zukunft des Irak nach dem Krieg gab
der Iran als großer Gorilla im Raum und
sein Einfluss auf die Schiiten wurde
einfach übersehen der Irak ist eine
Demokratie ja aber er ist jetzt eine
Demokratie und dem Einfluss des Irans
einer brutalen theokratischen
Diktatur der Iran ist also zweifellos
der größte Gewinner des Irakkriegs in
der Region und das ist das beste
Beispiel dafür dass die us-stategie
nicht gerade brillant war im zweiten
Teil dieses Videos werden wir daher auf
die Verantwortlichen und ihre Motive
eingehen die dieses Desaster
herbeigeführt haben als auch darauf wozu
dies alles noch führen wird und ich kann
euch garantieren dabei wird kein Auge
trocken bleiben also vergesst wie gesagt
nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen und in der
Zwischenzeit ist erstmal wieder eure
Meinung gefragt glaubt ihr 20 Jahre nach
dem Krieg dass es eine weise
Entscheidung war in den Irak
einzumarschieren oder um auf Buss Worte
zurückzukommen war es die Mühe wert den
Irak in eine Demokratie zu verwandeln
wie immer sind wir auf eure Kommentare
zu diesem heißen Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt
uns bitte ein Like das mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert es mit ihnen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
eine Spende von euch mit un dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video in diesem Sinne macht's gut und
bis
[Musik]
bald